tonnes en direct par téléphone avec fa
10 à 10 bonjour vous êtes entrepreneur à
beyrouth
la déflagration a été entendue dans
toute la capitale tout d'abord comment
est ce que vous l'avez vécu oui bonsoir
alors moi les choses comme tout le monde
j'étais sur mon canapé à me mêler de mai
de mes affaires et je suis me soucier de
problème existe au liban et tout d'un
coup on arrive des secousses donc
premièrement les 10 et traille des
meubles qui commence à trembler et puis
quelques secondes après une sorte de don
de choc qui nous a aidé un bruit
assourdissant qui nous a tous fait le
démentiel
et puis on essaie de regarder un peu
autour de nous ce qui ne veut pas se
faire sans vraiment comprendre alors
quelle est la situation en ce moment à
beyrouth et et autour du secteur du port
on évoquait il ya quelques dizaines de
minutes le ballet incessant des
ambulances et des camions de pompiers de
nombreuses personnes aussi bloquées sous
les débris
est-ce toujours le cas alors la
situation actuelle je ne pourrais pas
vous en parler avec ritchie avec le
préfet millon vu que moi même je me
trouve dans une partie de beyrouth qui
est assez éloignée du port est fait pour
ça que je voudrais vraiment souligner
est sûre la puissance de cette explosion
puisque même mois étant très loin du de
la grogne d'explosion gers en pied le
choc comme s'il était à côté
alors c'est vrai que même de là où je
suis on entend beaucoup de ce fait même
beaucoup de bruit c'est quelque chose je
t'en veux dire non comme à l'habitude à
beyrouth mer on n'entend plus que l'asie
du sud est est plus le fait de ne pas
savoir va et qui la fait passer après et
d'où vient à l'incidence chez qui nous
alertent le bus on imagine que toutes
les télévisions libanaises on se rend
même suivent la situation sur place
qu'est ce que vous voyez sur les écrans
que se passe-t-il autour de cette zone
du du port de beyrouth alors
premièrement je pense que peu importe où
vous vous trouvez dans beyrouth vous
allez pouvoir voir effectivement ne
de fumée rose orangé qui a jamais
vraiment pas de bonne augure sur les
réseaux on ne compare à un champignon
d'une tête nucléaire
donc il ya vraiment de nouvelles images
qui circulent à la cacophonie et d'image
de plusieurs angles de cette explosion
cette fumée et ce feu qui nous rappelle
que le liban a connu un autre désastre
aujourd'hui on évoque au moins dix morts
des centaines de blessés en appel au don
du sang rail a été lancé en pleine crise
sanitaire cause dit-il est ce que les
hôpitaux de beyrouth à parviennent à
faire face à la situation
encore une fois je vais vous répondre
avec les informations qui sont à ma
disposition
les hôpitaux de balle sont peut-être six
équipes et non pas les dispositifs pour
s'occuper
premièrement des mes crises sanitaires
telles que celle du collège mais si on
vient en plus rares et et par dessus des
blessés des morts des blessés graves et
des morts à sanaa pour à 40 chez à la
situation au liban et je pense que les
hôpitaux à ne pourront pas tu n'es pas
très longtemps comme ça allez les gars
on l'a dit son sont considérables la
déflagration était extrêmement puissante
racontez nous un peu les images qui
circulent aujourd'hui sur les télés
libanaise sur les réseaux sociaux à quoi
ressemble ou beyrouth à peine deux
heures après les explosions
beaucoup beaucoup de bruit et beaucoup
de poussière soulevée et et prendre
porsche trg souvent fait la même image
qui tourne beaucoup à celle du coût de
la deuxième explosion
quelle qualité la plus visuelle et la
plus puissante
je pense à étudier aussi beaucoup de
personnes dans la rue des personnes
neutres is des personnes qui à coups de
fil cet événement avec les autres
problèmes qui nous tombe dessus à
beyrouth et dans tout le liban donc deux
images bien pris les autorités du pays
ont tardé
réagir le premier ministre s'est
finalement exprimé pour décrété un jour
de deuil national ce mercredi demain le
président lui convoqué une réunion du
conseil supérieur de la défense ce soir
comment les libanais vivent t-il ce qui
peut être considéré comme un manque de
réactivité quel message à peut-être
aussi était passé depuis par les
autorités auprès de la population
alors c'est pas ce n'est pas un secret
la communication entre le peuple et puis
les les partis politiques et le
gouvernement n'a jamais été très amicale
mais moi je prend aussi en considération
qu avec la cacophonie des réseaux
sociaux
on a été beaucoup et il ya eu beaucoup
d'hypothèses de pour déterminer la cause
de cette explosion
et je pense que ce soit nous ou bien le
gouvernement on ne tient tant des pas du
tout et et il a fallu être sûrs et de ce
qui se passe pour pouvoir faire va faire
une annonce et même moment je pense que
nous ne sommes pas vraiment sûrs des
réelles causes de cet accident parce
qu'on rappelle pour l'instant l'origine
des explosions
reste inconnu s'agirait dans l'incident
dans le secteur du port que se dit il
dans le pays sur les éventuelles
circonstances de cet incident alors va
évidemment s'ils ont su un peu les
autres shows ça se dit tout et n'importe
quoi
donc ça va partir d'un charme accident
bête de feu d'artifice est qu'il ferait
pris dans une bagarre dans des produits
chimiques
ça va jusqu'à un acte terroriste
venant de l'intérieur du liban et venant
d'un mac et venant d'un autre pied à
l'extérieur donc personne ne sait
vraiment ce qu'il s'est passé personne
ne veut s'appuyer sur les faits ou ce
qui aurait pu vraiment se fâcher mais
chacun sa petite primorié et dans tout
ce bazar sur les trous de la vérité pour
l'instant car pour l'instant encore une
forme rappelle l'origine de ces deux
explosions restent inconnues alors vous
l'avez évoqué la situation économique du
liban extrêmement compliqué on imagine
que cela porte un nouveau coup dur aux
citoyens libanais déjà fortement
éprouvée
oui tout à fait moi j'habite ici depuis
depuis quelques années déjà je travaille
à beyrouth en tant qu'entrepreneur et la
suite des événements donc je ne parle
pas seulement de la révolution qui s'est
passé en octobre dernier il ya plusieurs
crises et plusieurs sujets qui s'appuie
kiffa lourde et sur des routes et le
liban et cette accumulation va faire
qu'à un moment on va arriver à un point
de rupture et de non retour
malheureusement donc les libanais sont
je pense ont envie de changement
mais il ya aussi un petit espoir qu'on y
arrivera jamais avec qui nous dirigent
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
fait 10 à 10